this guy's this guy's hi all right okay
uh we're gonna play medal okay one no no
two three four five six major zero seven
five ten eleven twelve
nine eleven stall that's when we're
family oh we're filming this on
September 11 never forget um never
forget Pearl Harbor was wrong no please
yeah yeah yes week oh god oh no oh you
can't stop the solids okay oh you
already did oh you stopped slurping that
soda in the microphone
nope okay you know let's get to the
actual game so then we got bored because
we're bad at games and I already knew
what happened neither of us can play
retro games okay I I played Resident
Evil 2 okay no data present on hard disk
drive please no did you remember to save
oh did you remember to save Jackson
gutsy we wait for like an hour
and we wanted to skip the hour of
cutscenes that precedes the gameplay and
then you forgot to say oh my god okay
okay man I should have just
oh god my phone okay I got it
alright thank you there's an Amber Alert
that's really sad but it's making my
phone ball up oh hey so I left a comment
on James Gunn the director of guardians
the galaxy's Facebook post and I don't
know if he's gonna respond yet but I
hope he does I asked him if there's
gonna be like Easter eggs related to
spider-man and guardians the galaxy 2 in
X X okay skip all this it basically goes
through like a PowerPoint presentation
that just gets you up to speed on the
Cold War we haven't know all of the Cold
War we have an intelligent audience of
psychopaths like myself who enjoy such
topic we're making that joke about Pearl
Harbor and you you said we said 12 9 and
say no it's 12 it was what December 9 is
when we started the war 1207 was only
happen we know ok
do you think wonderful haven't you sex
mail each fuckness you know second
birthplace absolutely address portsmouth
and why do we have as ad yeah now I can
skip everything so on what you doing
like snakes for some context for you
guys so uh you know I'm cutting that
whole part out it's better without
context ok check this Nathan Drake [ __ ]
I'm gonna climb this tree so good girl
oh you love it
are you ready you ready for this yet
boom yeah alright alright what'd you
write you write it you splatter all over
with how cool this is ready sterling oh
that was so good
oh he's making those noises I see you
achieved your backpack snake let's have
a 40 minute long conversation about
ethics of being a soldier in war a real
soldier doesn't do this this this and
this but also does this and politics are
the reason why this and this happens
because politics and war never changes
and Kojima which makes no sense in
either context and they're both complete
opposites it's almost like they were
intentionally one-upping each other
Hera medic here how many times I hit the
button to skip past all these lines of
dialogue that lady named boss talks for
like a solid 15 minutes about what it is
EBS soldiers an awesome CD just techno
it's agreeable it's just like really
shitty telegraphed don't question badly
done can you be louder can I be lover
yes you already got a chair for this no
be way louder like yell goddamnit
Oh Oh crikey that's a big one rabble I'm
gonna wash along he'll never see me
coming
oh god I'm sinking I'm ass-deep okay
alright go prone okay are you ready
okay notnot now you guys you gotta apply
the tactical espionage action
you gotta apply the key down scoop
method take this nature and see this is
a classic example
this killer croc crikey
he's gotta look at his eyes they're like
what what did you see his eyes disappear
is fades out like don't see the look in
his eyes as he as he transcends I saw
the look in his eyes as the life faded
out of his brain
did he it was it was like resignation
like I accept what's about to happen I'm
okay with the fact that this weird
ripoff of Snake Plissken a stabbing me
no no it's totally the Snake Plissken is
so good all right
they stood enough time he'll never stop
me
hey look it's Mortal Kombat X scorpion
no eggs
Mortal Kombat X the colors they look
exactly the same you're gonna see in the
video and your hero or whoever they look
nothing alike but I don't have an iPad
we got a complete escape from LA the
climax of the movie it's a [ __ ] camp
basketball game it even started it more
like like half an engine like someone
wearing a surgical mask and a hood that
happens a lot but it's a very specific
kind but it happens a lot
no you haven't why wait you hear a
change of camo okay all right
thank you for saying excuse me you're
like anything there's a it was a
dragonfly
collectibles why are there plants
growing around you hahahaha
Black Sea blackfish black fakes you mean
it's big red lips to be more racist no
all right racially insensitive naked
snake I hate this can but not because
it's bad because I love this game so
much
it's a out one correct no stop it
he'll never see me he'll never see me no
it's good to see you see he's changing
position because you're using less
camouflage now he's seen a meter stick
and autographs no that's what those are
free boots they're oh hey look there's
some ammo that this alligator crocodile
was guarding Jackson I've [ __ ] which
one is it um that now get her a
crocodile they never taught me the
different riders an ala dial
Kaka Gator and this is how you tell ok
so he opens his mouth in an a shape that
means it's a crocodile known it opens
his mouth and in the a shape that means
he's an [ __ ]
what knock it out yeah I kill them
oh we're some we're supposed to let them
loose alright let's go no mercy that
snake shows no mercy we're gonna hate
my enemies create this one through that
a whole PowerPoint would think I saw
something no you're going the wrong way
get it behind this [ __ ] tree you're
messing it up well oh they'll never see
me up here just a it I'm gonna perch up
here like Batman and drop down and like
bodyslam them you ready
slow down get back here oh very long
yeah yeah why are you murdering those
four men no made you see that
suspicious-looking American guy not too
busy looking at my phone wait for it
wait for it anyway let's go oh hey
what's up what oh hey Wow okay never
mind
oh there you are eat it I need to keep
too fast he's like sonic I don't know I
hope so huh we gotta get a good listen
Hey
nice snake
okay anyway stealth tactical espionage
espionage espionage that you
oh [ __ ] man gotcha well hurry it up dude
no it's it'll go to the side
okay go knife on me David and I are
having a conversation about Ninja
Turtles this is how did you fall
serpentine oh I get it cuz your snake
has no point it's just like a joke
like there's a difference between just
like a well but really any joke that
comes out of your mouth it upsets you
when I talk like you always just go oh
why don't I come your house I don't know
it's like we're friends or something
what we gotta get soaked along it's like
the eighth time you said that got it to
zero danger no come on
amazed you time I'm stepping through the
door John met John met Dodd Maddie you
know why they can't see you oh that was
that was so good
you like tactical role for no reason
well knife is dead no no no see this is
my brother Dmitri Dmitri Martin yeah and
all of his important things that show
should have never gotten cancelled if
you know what I'm talking about you win
five dollars five internet dollars
that's worth look his it's five American
dollars ah
anyway say it Crouch how do you guys see
you who is that
Crouch ah damn it blown again
always Otacon a lot of cons not here yet
no but Otto Kahn means the view I do
like yeah like perch up there like
Batman and then drop down an elbow drop
someone oh yeah just cutscene where it's
like your Russian is very good thank you
so is yours
in Russian like what no pop out cuz they
couldn't record the audio twice in two
different languages